polycystic ovary syndrome also called
PCOS is an imbalance of the female sex
hormones the ovaries are part of the
female reproductive system along with
the fallopian tubes uterus and vagina
your ovaries contain your lifetime
supply of eggs
these eggs are immature and are stored
in tiny fluid filled structures called
follicles
your pituitary gland located at the base
of the brain produces hormones that
direct the function of your ovaries each
month the pituitary gland secretes
follicle stimulating hormone or FSH and
luteinizing hormone or LH into the
bloodstream
after these hormones reach the ovaries
several hundred immature eggs start to
mature expanding the size of the
follicles
as the eggs mature the follicles secrete
estrogen the main female sex hormone
once the amount of estrogen in the blood
reaches a certain level
the pituitary sends a surge of
luteinizing hormone
to the ovaries
causing the most mature follicle to open
and release its egg in a process called
ovulation the free egg travels through
the fallopian tube where it awaits
fertilization
eventually the remaining immature
follicles and eggs dissolve
if the egg is not fertilized the egg and
the lining of the uterus are shed during
the next menstrual period
if you have polycystic ovary syndrome
your pituitary gland may release
abnormally high amounts of luteinizing
hormone into your bloodstream disrupting
your normal menstrual cycle as a result
your follicles do not mature and
ovulation does not occur which can lead
to infertility some of the immature
follicles do not dissolve and remain as
fluid-filled sacs or cysts
in addition your doctor may find your
blood has high levels of insulin a
hormone produced by the pancreas
too much insulin combined with high
levels of luteinizing hormone can lead
to excess production of a male hormone
called testosterone in your ovaries
abnormally high levels of testosterone
prevent ovulation which can lead to
infertility high levels of testosterone
also caused many of the physical
features associated with polycystic
ovary syndrome such as acne and abnormal
hair growth
having polycystic ovary syndrome raises
your risk for type 2 diabetes because of
excess insulin and insulin resistance
heart disease high blood pressure
cholesterol abnormalities in the blood
and endometrial cancer
since there is no cure for polycystic
ovary syndrome your doctor may recommend
one or more medications to treat your
symptoms such as hormonal birth control
which while preventing pregnancy also
regulates your menstrual cycle and
reduces testosterone production in your
ovaries anti-androgen medications which
reduce abnormal hair growth and acne
diabetes medications such as metformin
which lowers your insulin levels and
regulates your menstrual cycle and
fertility medications which can
stimulate ovulation so you can become
pregnant
if you want to become pregnant and
fertility medications have not succeeded
in restoring ovulation your doctor may
recommend laparoscopic ovarian drilling
during the procedure your surgeon will
insert a small needle into the ovary and
use an electric current to destroy small
areas of ovarian tissue where
testosterone is produced over time
testosterone production diminishes and
ovulation may occur